[Music]
thank you
foreign
productivity and success of the company
really does rely on the well-being of
the workforce you work you earn and you
eat if you do not work you won't eat
it's facing Us in the eye the students
have to be made aware they have to have
an opinion now realized that by 2050
there's only a 50 probability that we
are all going to survive
that this time we will have a strong
representation
25 people will be traveling
with Terry 10
suruchi badwal and I've been working
with Terry for the last 22 years in the
field of climate change the difference
between the heat wave of this year
versus what we've been hearing over the
last two decades earlier it was just
pocketed events in some part of the
country or the other but this year was
unique because two-thirds of the country
was under heat wave conditions with
consistently higher temperatures than
the normals of those regions for a
greater number of days
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
that's it
[Music]
we are a developing country urbanizing
at a very rapid Pace most of the cities
and the way they're growing in an
unplanned way is leading to the urban
heat island effect where we are trapping
hot air within certain areas
foreign
foreign
married
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
there might be a situation where
there'll be a three degree rise in
temperatures are you concerned yes
definitely
you know I love uh wondering about in
class and interacting with my students
but I found myself tiring so easily I'm
not necessarily an unhealthy person who
would you know faint due to other
reasons so it became clear to me that my
exposure to that temperature was the
trigger for you know me fainting we
being the age we are that we've gone
through the time when there was hail
thunder lightning rain temperature
freezing or very very hot and we went to
school so for us to comprehend why
schools should uh just because the
temperatures touched 40 degrees I am
totally against this policy the kids
need to be resilient I'm all for it I
try to go to open marketplaces but at
the moment you can't really go to those
places because
it's so hot
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
these blue seeds are not allowed because
they are fixed you need seed you need
seed not only protects the vendor this
also provides say to Consumers and
problem is that we do not have enough
green leaves also
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
of our people
who's accountable where is the
accountability in the system
I work at Shahi exports and I had the
organizational development team which is
responsible for programs on worker
well-being environmental sustainability
compliance among a few other areas
we run over 50 factories across nine
states in India and these employ over a
hundred thousand full-time workers
productivity and success of the company
really does rely on the well-being of
the workforce
basically
again
TV
foreign
measures to address the challenges
caused by heat stress we have a high
volume low speed fans which essentially
push down cool air we've installed LED
lights at the needlepoint when Shahi
converted to LED lights a few years ago
the temperature on the shop floor
reduced by 2.4 degrees Celsius so
through all these different measures
there's ways we can actually make sure
it's cooler inside than than outside by
a few degrees
foreign
because it guarantees employment in a
country the size of India providing
basic infrastructure in a village so so
all the things that could sustain a
rural community
gives you a choice to go to work at any
time of the year but what is the lean
time of year for work is the Heat season
so you have the highest number of people
turning up for work at the hottest time
of the year is unbearable
it's impossible almost to hold your
instruments and often the government
does actually reduce the work Norms
during those months and it does change
timings so they're not looking at it
from a point of view of workers they're
not giving that self-management the
opportunity that it should have
[Laughter]
strong demand
let us determine our work
I think actually if we were to pay more
attention to the people most affected
which is the poor which are who are
workers who are farmers who produce
everything that that we have today I
think we will perhaps find better
solutions for
for all of us as an economy and for the
globe certainly
[Music]
is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we actually have 70 of our electricity
requirement coming from renewable
sources climate change is definitely a
factor in our decision-making process
there needs to be more urgency around
this there also needs to be more
research and understanding around how
businesses can adapt to these changing
conditions you know once they have a
better understanding I believe that can
drive action
there at the concentrations out there
are because of the developed countries
and therefore the negotiations basically
on how the developing countries can get
assistance from the developed countries
with regard to climate finance and
appropriate technology to be able to
adapt to the consequences of the
changing climate
there is facing Us in the eye these are
real issues
I mean workers have to survive they are
most vulnerable so they have a critique
they had a critique far before we did we
have only come to that critique because
suddenly we find that the entire Earth
that we are living on is under threat
foreign
[Music]
students have to be made where they have
to have an opinion now at the end of the
day we are the ones who have to face the
brunt of it I should be the one taking
the steps to stop climate change rather
than uh depending on some old politician
who probably won't be there in 2050 as
well they are not precious dolls they
better learn what reality is yes cop 26.
uh many countries came together and
um you know gave really motivational
speeches that will be we claim to have
Net Zero missions by 2050 2060 2017
Etc why are these goals so such
long-term goals the world leaders of
today will not take any responsibility
for what happens in 2050 or 2060. we
should have a cop conference in millions
of places around the earth not amongst
the policy makers but amongst the people
most effective the bills are being paid
by us the costs are on us and the
bureaucrats and the decision makers are
still not account
overall issue that we're talking about
thank you also very much you need
countries and bureaucrats and policy
makers to come forward and Regulation
and litigation there is no second earth
on which we can basically you know
migrate you get your act together or or
be ready for mass extinctions
if we continue the same way and the
patterns I think it's a question of
survival for you the human race is life